ciao a tutti ragazzi ebbe solo video
sono domenico lo più ci stiamo stilando
sempre più su fall guys mi sento
veramente è euforico e carico per
un'altra partita mi stanno andando molto
bene quindi è il momento giusto per
registrarlo ragazzi partiamo con sissoko
che mamma mia che palle che palle
dicono che pare perché quello dove in
genere molto più spendo muoio mai
all'inizio non mi è mai successo lontano
non mi è mai successo di morire mai però
effettivamente sì so è quello che soffro
tra virgolette un po di più perché vita
proprio guidami mi crea l'ansia sto
carchidi giochino comunicato l'ansia
totale e quindi vediamo di arrivare alla
fine in modo decente perfetto finora
tutto ok me lo state mettendo nella
parte sbagliata giratelo perfetto grazie
ragazzi che tocca anche a noi siete
molto gentili non so come ringraziarvi e
tutto è tutto in bilico suo livello è
orribile e rappresenta la mio percorso
scolastico story del perfetto ci siamo e
alla fine ho aspettato un'ora e mezzo in
quel punto ma sono arrivato 3 più di 7
nice allora ragazzi prima schedatura
veloce e fuori dalle balle molto bene 42
mening ho notato che dall'ultima fece
non so come mai e magari non è un
presentimento mio ma rimangono sempre un
sacco di persone in più dopo il primo
round perché primo round della settimana
scorsa
lenta rimanevano dopo invece stavolta 40
42 non so se è cambiato qualcosa però
boh la next one tra l'altro ag hanno
distribuito i cactus ultimamente vedo
tutti i vestiti così network in india io
sono l'unico vestito così che non sto
scherzando ma credo che la mia skinner
sia lui leggendaria perché comunque non
è leggendaria epica lo so però non c'era
quasi nessuno e non sto scherzando se ci
fate caso nessuna mia stima
sono l'unico ad averla non ancora visto
un cristiano con la mia fine neanche
mezzo è stato safari fa impazzire me la
fa sembrare strana ra il mega figo sono
primo sono primo e sarò primo non è vero
sto zitto ok sto zitto va bene sto zitto
e quarto
arrivare primo banco non cambia niente
prova hanno fissato questa cosa ci
vogliono due round per arrivare a 30
prima arriva via 30 in un solo quindi
già buone uscite ragazzi una patch
appunto questi giorni quindi hanno
corretto delle cose spero non abbiano
corretto questo perché la tattica giusta
come vi dico sempre è rimanere a lato
perché se rimani a lato ti colpisce meno
frutta seguiti però è praticamente
saranno corretto non lo so per adesso
tutto a posto anche se la la frutta
rivas paratissima ok saltando aumenta un
po la velocità in realtà saltate che
questi vanno più veloci
avete venduto l'anima al diavolo che è
successo che è successo vabbè hexagon
che culo speriamo di giocarcela bene
ragazze che a suo carico scarico me una
pigna con la vigna
ok marrello fa niente lo fai niente date
non ci devo rimanere lì sopra perfetto
piano fianco a fianco di maria da abbia
trattenuto suo presente maledetto mi ha
trattenuto ma togliti che la gente non
si toglie da farli cadere perché sennò
non ha senso dalla piano piano piano
piano ma perché la gente rompere madame
andate via
fate schifo puzzate più che ansia di
vivere piano piano piano che possono
solo più calmo fa chiamato bello calmo e
pacato piu grande perche i ragazzi sono
i due massimi 2 perfetto perfetto da che
prova a tagliare un po di strada no
correre di qua
magari maledetto schifoso l'aido muori
maria staccati dalle mie dai ragazzi ma
dai ma perché devi rompere le balle a me
può riassumersi in tre ragazzi non è
vero non è vero
non è vero no no si ott io sono ancora
ci credo oddio no ma non ci voglio che
leggo mi sono salvato bye bye bye
l'ultimo livello avete fa niente 2 6 1 6
eccolo un'elipista l'altro non lo vedo
raga non lo vedo non lo vedo
vado piano piano piano rimasto uno solo
e rio solo quello sono quello ti prego
spiegano toni proprio lui perché lui
proprio lui nei kg so much to va dosato
faccio dopo ne faccio un'altra la
vittoria non per voi ragazzi passiamo
alla seconda vediamo se riusciamo a
farne due in un video allora forte
fortissima in faccia race to finish
proviamo a vedere se ci riesco ragazzi
non lo so toglietevi fate schifo tutti
dai che ci culo che culo bisogna
lanciato a pesce nuovo ma come mai mi
devi rompere le balle ma cosa ti ammazzo
non arrivi da nessuna parte se ero io
guarda se mi trattenevo la mente
se mi sostenevano a me all'inizio
tornavo invece io trattengo gli altri e
non gliene frega niente continuano gli
altri mi possono spingere e io non posso
stringere gli altri gli altri vi possono
trattenere e io non posso trattare gli
altri questa è la regola corner
shoulders dipende dal team spero di non
i capitali in un team di stupidi
io faccio il mio in questo la ognuno fa
il suo però quelli coi team ragazzi tu
puoi essere bravo quanto vuoi ma c'è
talmente tanta gente che va veramente
solo a culo allora prendiamo le balle
gialle sempre una in difesa bavaro
sempre un in difesa sempre uno sempre un
indifeso telescopes a quella prendiamo
benissimo ok questo l'ho buttata agli
occhi o non c'è nessuno in difesa perché
fate schifo perché la sposti giallo
perché la sposti sei dei nostri ok dai
fermo bravissimo 7 secondi 4 palle let's
golf
quattro pale paurosa 21 perfetto
rimanete sempre in difesa uno a destra
il massimo strano un casino io devo
coprirne 2
mamma mia alla fine abbiamo vinto anche
quelli con più palle la prova per chi se
ne frega attaccare ma anche difendere
uguale difendere importante quanto
attaccare con poteri più 26 remaining
sto pensato quale potrebbe farvi uscire
il secondo me line lo slime quella
salita dello slime no perfect man o
perfect match ragazzi fa ridere perché
non muore mai nessuno a meno che non lo
spingano quindi ma facciamole veloce per
me è orribile
non ho mai capito sono abruzzo raggi x
che
facciamo perché troppo ridicolo però
vabbè next quanti sono caduti 01
fantastico design climber è veramente
maldestro raga perché la gente malata ti
spinge ricordatevi in slide climb non
vuoi morire perché arrivi ultimo
quindi stai tranquillo l'unica roba non
ti far leccare lo sai che continua a
salire
ragazzi questo è importante anche per
ora puoi arrivare ultimo perché non è
una gara si classificano tutti volendo a
questo sembra facile ma bisogna sempre
prendersi un attimo che ti scivola
perfetto 18 classificata fini sono
caduti jane 4 pensate che casini nostro
gioco sembra facile 17 17 remake va bene
let's go non provare a fermarmi ti
ammazzo cosa fai tanto chissenefrega
facciamo anche le trovate round over
ragazzi andiamo sul gran finale vediamo
che succede
ed è hexagon famiglia di nuovo speriamo
giacché mandata bene prima senza tattica
e ragga perché funziona la fine dipende
se non scivolo prima è andata vatan
prima ero ho finito ed altro mancava
ancora un livello finale quindi era
andata anche fin troppo bene siamo in
otto come prima cosa mi lamento a fare
all'inizio
rimaniamo qua ragazzi prendiamo tempo
vediamo tempo frate siamo in due
grazie mai spinto nel punto giusto però
il mio personaggio è stupido ma già al
mcdonald e quindi euro
e difficile dei movimenti capito la
facciamo che uscendo ancora un'altra
volta che dice persone che è pericolosa
e siamo sul finale ragazzi e pericoloso
scendere il piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano va bene va bene di
nuovo va bene è qua devo scendere larga
per forza però vedrai non è male non è
male non è male non è male non è male
non è male ragazzi non è male per niente
ok cani con la calma di tutta la gamma
del mondo tutta la calma del mondo ok ok
ok va bene uno contro uno attenzione
[Musica]
anzi i ragazzi il re del hexagon ma cosa
vi devo dire sono bravissimo a fare le
hexagon quindi ragazzi questo era le
visioni for guys di oggi sono molto
soddisfatto provare a giocare con
qualcuno magari nei prossimi episodi
vediamo cosa succede
però per adesso sono molto contento di
come gioco anche da solo perfetto
riguarda altri consigli guardatemi video
su folk ice volete divertirvi anche
perché spero di farvi divertire
iscrivetevi a calare che usciranno tutti
i giovedì e tutti in un edificio di paul
guys appunto mentre ragazzi scritti dal
canale lasciato tasto mi piace
commentata queste splendide vittorie di
fila e noi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo
bella ragazza
[Musica]